what's up y'all kelly clarkson has
arrived in new york city
it's season three from new york city
y'all hope you're ready
they call me the fireman oh that's
literally
coming to you from new york city y'all
are ready for this
[Music]
all right y'all we are hanging out
you look so cute ready this is river and
remy and felix and we are hanging out
today at fire zone to find out
information on the happiest days
and go through this fun little course
are you all excited yeah
you look real cute you got to keep my
hat for the whole thing
[Music]
nine one one
[Music]
look at gigi holding that
she's playing y'all
thank you so much felix for today you're
welcome i love you you are now an
official member
that was so cool that how they teach
kids um fire safety and honestly um i'm
39 and i learned a few things so
sad um but we're gonna safety first at
my house from now on so you should watch
this episode with your family
[Music]
a new york man who went from serving
time to serving ice cream and becoming a
pillar of his community he opened mikey
likes it ice cream in new york's lower
east side all right mikey just asking if
there was a kelly clarkson flavor
obviously would be amazing but what
would go into that
um we're going to call it
casey's masterpiece oh
sounds good
oh my god that's so good mike i gotta
hit your play shopping
all right i promised you now i was
[Music]
okay i'm in control of the camera so
this is gonna fail all right all right
i'm just hanging out with mikey i told
him i'll show up
and we are having some ice cream
so this is
our your freshman ice cream oh my god
i'm so excited this ice cream is a
restaurant with chocolate chip cookie
dough brownie tail pizzas and semi-sweet
chocolate chips
this is so good thank you i'm glad you
like it oh my gosh that's fresh mint
it's so good
um i gotta show you something real good
that we made i don't think i've been
looking at the right camera thing
um just take a little quick gander bat
yeah that's the melts of goodness and it
tastes amazing and i just found out
mikey where i'm supposed to be looking
because i'm old
i like it
mikey likes it oh my gosh i got that ice
cream for my job today so i'm winning
[Music]
what's up i don't know if you can hear
the music i'm a jimmy fallon
[Music]
i'm very excited um because i'm here in
person
i am walking out with this
to the stage and then i get to reveal my
face
so i kind of feel like it seems cool
[Music]
so we're at coney island today
i am so excited to beat dino and his own
park his own family park we're gonna i'm
gonna kill it
on a scale of one to ten i am 11 at
being competitive hold on spinal tap 11.
here's the thing i'm i'm fine at losing
i'm not a sore loser but who aims to not
win
a loser so yeah i'm excited dino's going
down
so listen i'm about to play kelly in
whatever game she wants to play and i
feel really confident you know
i'm a competitive person but she
she really has a problem she's like next
level nut ball competitive getting
touched up to win i want to look real
good when i beat you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
they let me win the first two and then i
was like no i want to do it for real and
then i really won that's right
my favorite part of new york so far is
definitely coney island one i just love
oh my god i'm about to go on the wonder
wheel and i'm watching it right now and
i'm so excited
i've been to new york so much since i
was like a sophomore in high school and
i don't know how i've never been able to
oh i know how i work a lot but um anyway
this is my favorite part because who
doesn't love this look at this
look at this
look at that wonder whale that i'm about
to ride
i hope i don't vomit okay bye
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
can we go one more time
we had so much fun at coney island y'all
you gotta come check this place out i
cannot believe it's taken me years to
get here bye
all right y'all so today we are in
central park and we are shooting the
opening music video and i'm wearing
and then i'll switch into my heels
but we're making so much fun we have
some surprise guests in the music video
i hope you love it but if you don't
whatever i did
surprised
[Music]
sorry thank you thank you
[Music]
my favorite part of today's shoot was
the subway because it went through the
sun
because we're all sweaty we got new york
rain we got new york heat we got a new
york subway vibe which was amazing looks
like gotham city
it's awesome
[Music]
it's show day new york city we're on our
way out to the set which looks beautiful
my
our apartment killed it everybody had
killed it
will you explain how this game works
this is your show it's your game
congrats kelly on season three i hope
you'll continue to have me back
and then i thought maybe you needed a
new car
it's what you needed don't look at it
oh my gosh one show down four to go
i'm so happy to see you i know
i'm excited
[Applause]
[Music]
one more show new york city we're doing
it
[Music]
thank you for having my initials put up
in your new studio those are minecraft
[Applause]
[Music]
y'all have a great day and if it's not
great change it
so that wraps up today i'm so excited
for season three i'm so excited that we
started here in new york city i love
this city so thank you new york i've
said it before i'll happily say it again
we love new york
[Music]
you